from Marcus I Michael I love your show
my question when should we hit a bully
back twice as hard and when should we
turn the other cheek
please answer using biblical references
people misunderstand this all the time a
lot of people who would just take
Christianity to be just some small
aspect of it they'll become pacifists
they'll say we should never punch back
don't ever fight back
they've only read a couple lines of the
Bible and they'll say see it says this
they haven't read the other things GK
Chesterton wrote an orthodoxy that
heresy is not the promotion of Vice it's
the just the promotion of one virtue to
the exclusion of all the others that's
what they're getting at but don't forget
to classy ass T's there is a time for
everything and a season for every
purpose under heaven there's a time for
war and a time for peace in the same
breath that Christ says turn the other
cheek
he also says if your right eye causes
you to sin pluck it out and throw it
away I don't know that he means that
literally if your right hand causes you
to sin cut it off and throw it away I
don't know that he means that literally
as we mean literally he says do not say
anything other than yes or no everything
else that you say comes to evil of
course he doesn't mean that literally
because he says many other things and he
tells st. Paul takes many oaths it takes
many vows he says only pray in your
inner closet but then Christ praise in
public as well so Christ also says to
the Apostles if you don't have a sword
sell your cloak and buy one he says that
very explicitly st. Augustine and st.
Thomas Aquinas both explained just war
very well all the reasons when wars can
legitimately be undertaken Santa Claus
himself st. Nicholas punched a heretic
in the face at the first Council of
Nicaea when we're talking about that
Sermon on the Mount Christ sums up the
whole sermon in the next chapter he says
seek first his kingdom and his
righteousness and all these things shall
be yours as well that's what he's
telling us seek first the kingdom of God
then follow everything else and then he
gives us these examples these parabolic
examples these hyperbolic examples do
not you shouldn't strike back at
somebody for spite or for cruelty or
even really for vengeance so I don't
think that you should be doing it say ah
that'll hurt him and that will give me
pleasure and joy but our Lord is also
not telling us to be doormats and to let
the cruel rape the face of the earth
Christ is speaking of a spiritual
strategy to Humble the self and to win
other souls over to him but not
everybody is moved
necessarily by this humility so we
should love our neighbors as ourselves
but sometimes we all need a little bit
of tough love don't we a priest friend
of mine keeps a baseball bat near the
door of his rectory because it's not a
great neighborhood there have been
break-ins and burglaries of the poor box
I one time asked him about this and he
explained it to me sometimes there just
isn't time to turn the other cheek
that's my feeling as well